part of the film is shot in Georgia
Savannah yes we shot two weeks in
Savannah and about a month in Rajasthan
India Wow okay from your observations
what can Bollywood teach American
filmmakers and vice versa it's a great
question I have never worked with harder
working people than the folks that I
worked with in Rajasthan we brought in
about 200 crew members from Mumbai by
train so they had to take this three-day
train ride to get to Rajasthan because
Rajasthan zhan the india-pakistan border
so it's way up there and they brought
the camera they brought everything you
know everything comes from and by on
train and they would do things that I
have never seen any crew in America do
where anything you asked them to do
anything that needs to be done it's done
instantaneously quickly and quite
efficiently I would take those people on
the crew that we had with me anywhere
they were fantastic and I think that we
can certainly learn something about
their work ethic because if people
worked as hard as they do there on films
I think you'd see a lot of independent
films here get made a lot faster so
efficiency and readiness to help maybe
know like well that's not my job there
is no there's not that type of job
there's only let's get it done and that
to me was quite impressive and then in
return what can American filmmakers
teach Bollywood well I think that
American film in Bollywood film are two
very very different things culturally
they have different identities in many
ways and with desires of the heart I was
trying to make a American film that had
Bollywood elements not the other way
around
because I think that to an American
audience most Bollywood films aren't
accessible to them for various cultural
reasons so I would say if a Bollywood
film wants to be successful out of India
they could learn something about the way
that Western filmmakers tell stories
because for better or worse
Western filmmaking is what has
influenced the global film market
outside of bollywood bollywood is its
own thing and that's why their films
they make so many films they make a
thousand films a year but only maybe a
tenth of them or less are going to find
a market outside of India and that's why
because they're really not designed for
Western audience I'm not saying that's a
bad thing that's how it is
do you see the same exuberance in
America for our stars or actors as you
do with the Bollywood stars in India
Bollywood stars are on a whole different
level
IRA Loren who's the American lead in the
film he and I would laugh about that
because Goshen Grover who's our
Bollywood lead over there is a huge star
in India and we were filming one day in
the middle of the desert in this town
that has no running water cow patty
Hut's they easily couldn't find a movie
theater because they don't have
electricity and the closest one might be
hours away and when we arrived to film
in their village with Goshen Grover the
entire village showed up because they
all knew who Goshen was I have a
fantastic picture of that Singh on
Instagram somewhere with like hundreds
of people swarming Val and Goshen in
this chair while they're waiting for the
next scene to be shot and that was
incredible to observe that people that
don't have televisions and don't have a
theater that they can go easily see a
film at would know instantaneously that
this guy is a huge Bollywood star and
know him and know what he's from because
they read the magazines and they see the
different things without going to the
theater or without watching them on
television that to me was fascinating
and that's the kind of cultural
differences they think you see between
Indian film and American film because if
Tom Cruise were to show up people would
be very excited to see him and don't get
me wrong but I don't know if you would
see that kind of excitement in the
far-flung regions of the United States
like you do
the entire town literally shows up so
that's how they're finding out about the
movies and these stars is through
magazines or magazines yeah it's at
which I thought was really interesting
you know being in a town that has no
electricity that all of them knew who he
was and a remote town not even somewhere
close to a city they don't have cars and
so that was fascinating to me
you